y'a tout le monde fait ce quiz y ait des
gens c'est un plaisir de parler avec
vous salut à tous les amis c'est julien
millet pokémon en bon je sais pas
comment commencer cette vidéo wii non je
voulais quand même juste vous dire un ou
deux trucs
voilà ça fait déjà six mois qu'on a
cette relation sur internet
cette relation en ligne et je me suis
dit qu'il était peut-être temps qu'on
passe aux choses sérieuses vous et moi
mais qu'il était peut-être temps que
qu'on se rencontre
hier elle donc dans les mois qui
viennent pour ceux qui ont envie on va
avoir l'occasion se croisaient ça
commence vendredi 18 novembre au salon
européen de l'éducation à paris expo
porte de versailles avec quelques
collègues youtuber ont fait une table
ronde avec les professionnels de
l'éducation
mais on a aussi prévu un petit pique
nique avec vous tous entre midi et 13
heures 45
tout le monde peut venir l'entrée est
gratuite on se pose on mange on discute
ce sera à la cool donc rendez vous à
midi sur le stand de la ligue de
l'enseignement au salon européen de
l'éducation
je ne parlais pas la bouche pleine tout
passe mal bon dans un registre un peu
différent en avril je serai aussi à
vidéo city paris bon je serai pas tout
seul je rate deux trois collègues avec
moi je ne sais pas si vous connaissez ce
sera les 8 et 9 avril
devinez où à paris expo porte de
versailles incroyable bon c'est dans
longtemps on aura l'occasion d'en
reparler d'ici là et même après 1 en
aura d'autres occasions de se croiser
tête même en chronos on sépare bon je
peux pas en parler
on verra ça plus tard en attendant un
grand merci à tous d'être là un grand
merci à tous d'être aussi nombreux est
aussi sympa un grand merci à tous pour
vos messages qui font chaud avant petit
appareils cardiovasculaires
je vous embrasse tous à bientôt
ah oui et surtout portez vous bien